what will be the seismic shifts in the
year ahead the appearance of this outfit
convulsed world politics for several
years struck fear into the hearts of
people all around the world Islamic
state is the most vicious and murderous
jihadist regime the world has ever seen
in 2017 it will be smashed the defeat of
Islamic state will be one of the most
significant things to happen and 2017
this was the biggest boldest attempt by
jihadism to set up an alternative form
of government to defy not as the West to
defy the whole world order to defy lines
on maps to create a completely religious
based and extremely violent government
tonight I want to speak to you about
what the United States will do with our
friends and allies to degrade and
ultimately destroy the terrorist group
known as ISIL forces from some 60
countries have taken the fight to
Islamic state it now clings to two key
strongholds one in Iraq and one in Syria
Islamic state has been driven out of
almost all the territory they used to
hold in Iraq at one point they had a
third of the country they are down just
holding a part of Mosul in Syria they
have been driven out of almost
everything they held an attention will
shift to Raqqa the Islamic state capital
in Syria quite swiftly after that
controlling territory is what defines
Islamic state recruits have been drawn
from all over the world to fight for its
declared domain the objectives were to
remain and expand and to remain really
as the important thing here to be more
than just a terrorist outfit to be an
alternative government if that goes then
whole way of looking at the world goes
with it in October 2016 an iraqi-led
force launched a concerted effort to
reclaim Mosul that's meeting some stiff
resistance as it gets closer into the
city itself but they are one-by-one
taking out his
state leaders the city is set to fall
within months with the Syrian stronghold
of Raqqa and a few remaining pockets
likely to follow shortly after but many
of the fighters themselves may outlast
Islamic state the terrible danger is
that in 2017 the people that fought with
Islamic state will feel just as
discontented as ever they did and will
return not to holding territory but to
committing acts of horrible violence
against the people that are trying to
rebuild the country for the West - it
may prove a Pyrrhic victory the dangers
that we saw coming to cause great
bloodshed in 2016 on the streets of
Europe will be even greater in 2017
because there is no Islamic state
existing as a state for people to go and
fight for so they may go and fight as
well the fall of Islamic state will not
mean the end of terrorism won't mean
that peaceful calm that atrocities will
cease that jihadism as an idea will be
defeated however something very
significant will have happened I think a
philosophy or psychology that says that
you can create a wholly new geographical
entity call of the state transcend the
existing established order of borders
that idea will have been smashed to see
that disappear that's that's really
fantastic news
you